take me to your leader no I did have one
DMT trip way back like maybe the second
or third or fourth way back where it was
completely different it's the only one
I've ever had like that and it was
completely different and the way I you
put it to myself
was the big people were home and it was
an entirely different feeling and many
people actually I've never quite had
this myself but many people report DMT
trips where they broke in on an entity
who is not pleased at all and demands to
know how the hell you got there and you
know you know very assertive dialogues
go on and one person described being
then just hurled through all of time
like exploded back from this thing and
going through all the recapitulation of
ontogeny and it's weird stuff
DMT trips I mean mine are always as I
described but some people report and
these may be synergies with
antidepressants or something like that
but apparently very stable and strange
world
I mean worlds with alien people's and
animals and cities and you know very
science fictiony stuff that's why this
Bell's Theorem I don't think we use that
word but this nonlocality that we talked
about may have something to do with the
phenomenon of the imagination like it's
occurred to me over the years that what
we call imagination might simply be
hyper dimensional perception and you're
actually seeing worlds and places that
truly exist somewhere
scattered through
the galaxy's like grains of sand but no
place you will ever contact or visit in
the flesh but that the batter is somehow
present there seems to be some kind of
tuning thing that needs to go on I you
know possibly with technology I had a
really weird experience years ago I took
LSD one evening with a bunch of people
and it was fairly casual and social and
smoked a bunch of weed this went on for
a couple of hours and it didn't really
ever seem to come on it just seemed to
be very light and then I climbed on my
motorcycle and went home and decided I
would go to bed and I decided that I
would smoke that one last joint before
going to bed and I had one of those
standeth electrical resistance heaters
that you get in at the Salvation Army
you know if you're a Porsche student and
I said so I turned it on as I started to
smoke this joint and it was badly wired
and it made this sound like
and as I began to listen to the sound I
like went to lizard land and I entered
into this completely coherent thing
which lasted for hours about this world
inhabited by these intelligent reptilian
beings and we went through their art
their history their theories of jewelry
making their philosophy their polity
their science their religion their
fashion there and it was like reptilian
world
well then later I tried again I took LSD
with my arm around my heaters I've been
preaching it in the streets and I could
never really find my way which is a
typical phenomenon of higher higher
dimensional phase space wealth taught me
you know doing the reverse of what you
did doesn't fear you back to where you
started you have to find your way
forward through the matrix
you